a very meaningful tangible and important
outcome for apec this year
what another second outcome of course is
that
we will now see going forward the lens
of climate change
applied to future apec policy and that
just did not exist a year ago let alone
three years ago our next question comes
from anna white from tbnz killer prime
minister uh we've seen a warning from
chinese president xi jinping
of relapsing into the confrontation of
division and cold in of the cold war era
in light of auxis and if it's to counter
china's influence in the region what are
your views
on his fears and what are the discussion
and reaction of apec members
in
in in response to this
well when i reflect on
the contributions made by leaders today
i throughout the discussion was taking a
note of the common themes and what
really struck me
was just the consistency with which
leaders were referring time and time
again
to the same frame of reference and one
of those most consistent themes was as
we discussed climate change
sustainability
the second was of course the response to
the global pandemic and the need for us
to focus obviously on recovery but also
vaccination programs
but the third was a critical focus on
trade no discussion or debate
around the need for us to keep supply
chains open to ensure that we have the
free flow of goods and services and the
importance of trade in our recovery in
fact one of the i think remarkable uh
things about
the past year
uh as we have been in the role of host
is that this is the exact time in an
economic shock like this that you would
expect potentially retrenchment and
nationalism in the way that we treat
critical goods and services or trade
policy generally and yet we have not
seen that this year and i don't
underestimate the power of apec as a
body and ensuring that that didn't occur
in fact the opposite we saw goods and
services critical to the pandemic
in fact have tariffs removed
of course when it comes to trade there
are a number of forums we will continue
to promote that free and open
free and open movement
and
the next wto meeting
is of course another critical juncture
but for apex part i think we've seen
actually what is possible when we come
together and seek global solutions in
time of crisis
now over to michael nielsen from the new
zealand herald uh dnr queer prime
minister michael um i've got a question
on the cp tpp yeah many members are part
of this trade agreement and china and
taiwan have applied to join too uh china
brought this up this week what what
discussions were there around these
applications by leaders and has the u.s
expressed any interest in joining the
agreement
yeah of course as i've already indicated
trade was a significant part of the
dialogue for
the apec leaders meeting as as you would
expect
cptpp of course is
a demonstration point
of the importance of multilateral
agreements and continuing to open up
trade opportunities for member economies
as is rcep
but they are instruments that sit
independent of apec of course apec
economies a number of them are engaged
in these agreements but they are not
apec tools or instruments themselves so
as you'd expect
used as a reference point an example of
areas of interest for members of
economies to join but actually the
process of joining is very much for
the cptpp commission the member
countries and as they've they've
repeatedly said as we've repeatedly said
any country who wishes to meet the high
standard
of the cptpp of course is is welcome to
enter into that process
our first virtual question now from ivan
watson from cnn please unmute yourself
go ahead and ask your question
uh thank you very much uh prime minister
you you talked about
a response to the covet pandemic
i wanted to ask did the members discuss
the potential challenges or even threats
of disinformation when it comes
to vaccine mandates and
coveted restrictions
and i ask that within the context of
calls for protests in your own country
and
signs of
that some of the restrictions may be
hurting your party and your own personal
uh approval
was disinformation discussed and are
there potential solutions for dealing
with distrust about public health
measures in the face of a pandemic
thank you for the question
uh look i was i'm mindful that i'm here
answering questions as chair of apec but
one thing i'd reflect is
both the high and growing rates of
vaccines for many member economies of
apec and if i were to reflect here as
host country
by way of example for new zealand's
eligible population 90
of new zealanders have received their
first dose of a vaccine so
rather than a demonstration of being
fractured i think in many ways it
demonstrates the unity around seeing
vaccines as a solution and apec
economies you can see from the dialogue
around vaccines is very much the view
that vaccines sit centrally as part of
the region's
management and recovery
i refer if i may actually to the opening
comments of the managing director of the
imf who restated the imf's goal to see
globally first
doses um
goals for first doses and then second
doses reaching 70
of the world's population by the middle
of 2022.
so there's a shared view within apec
economies that we must make sure
that
every opportunity is had within apic
economies for citizens to be vaccinated
and a very clear focus on working
together to share creative ideas um
ensure logistically we overcome any
barriers and certainly that's been a
focus of apec and just try and achieve
the highest rates of vaccine for our
region that we can because we know that
is the best way that we can get back to
business open up uh the flow of people
goods and services our next question is
from james already from the wall street
journal kia ora james
uh hello prime minister i acknowledge
it's quite early there or late for you
so thank you for taking the time
um the leader
leadership declaration refers to the
extraordinary disruption in trade due to
covet
and that's true for economies as well
but if we consider uh covet as more of a
temporary issue a temporary disruption
what are the implications for
the broader political and economic
disruption in the west's relationship
with china
and and what do you think uh is is the
uh outcome or what what is your response
to news that the us and chinese
presidents will meet virtually in the
next few days
thank you
well of course as apec economies we
would welcome the ongoing bilateral
dialogue between uh
apec members of course and as i welcome
some of the more recent resolutions that
we've seen from cop26 in that regard
between the united states and china
when it comes to
the impact of the pandemic on trade
flows
actually what strikes me is that we have
two contrasting uh issues that have
arisen uh from the pandemic you know
across the board we're all experiencing
uh supply chain issues whilst we have of
course increasing demand and the number
of impacts that that's having on our
economies
and that is universal no country has
been spared from the impact of that
and yet at the same time
we are seeing greater energy going into
and trying to actually overcome those
logistical barriers and see the free
flow of goods and services and if i were
to hark back to an example that we used
uh as an outcome from our extraordinary
meeting mid-year
here we saw the pandemic present an
opportunity for us to identify the
urgency of moving goods particularly
vaccines at the border moving beyond
paper-based processing needing to remove
tariffs spread on vaccines or
consumables used as part of the response
to the pandemic so where there may have
been potentially in the past an
opportunity
or an area where you may have seen forms
of
protectionism or nationalism and the
response you saw the opposite a real
commitment from apec economies to
overcome those issues
now for me that's emblematic of what's
possible so that demonstrates to me what
we as economies can achieve when we
recognize a joint problem when we are
absolutely committed to overcoming it
the next venture in that regard i
believe is in climate goods and services
and then from there let's use that as a
benchmark to continue to see the removal
of barriers to trade
and look whether we do that at a
plurilateral a multilateral or a
bilateral level
that bodes well for our our region
generally
our next question is from brandon tonato
from channel news asia please ask your
question
hi prime minister thank you so much for
taking questions i do have a question on
the reopening of borders and travel
fronts
what tangible outcomes does the group
and members hope to see by next year and
what steps are being taken right now and
what are some of the challenges that are
being expected thank you
yeah thank you um a great question uh of
course you know a long-term focus of
apec has always been
and if you hark back to some of the
tangible outcomes in the past that apec
has achieved very focused on the
movement of
not only goods but of course people
and particularly from an economic
perspective those engaging in economic
activity from country to country
and so there is a natural interest for
apec members in this area and a natural
role for apec to play
apec however has sought to actually make
gains in areas as quickly as possible so
they were involved in
uh helping we were involved apec and
helping formulate safe travel
opportunities and
um uh
plans uh for flight crew and that's had
a knock-on effect uh and benefits of
course uh goods moving uh moving through
aviation and of course uh helping to
ensure we still have people moving
between borders i think that
demonstrates where we have a value add
of course generally for border reopening
there's a number of issues at play
different economies at different points
in their reopening
issues around the interoperability of
vaccine certificates and recognition of
vaccines but i do believe going forward
apec will continue to have a useful role
to play as we navigate these issues
over to celia hassan now from the bbc hi
there cilia
hello hello prime minister well before
you started speaking when you just spoke
just now i understood that there was a
lack of consensus surrounding the u.s
offer to host apec in 2023
can you update us on that and the
discussions that have been going on
regarding the u.s offer what were the
concerns regarding uh the u.s
role as a host
i would actually instead just simply
frame it as a
an issue that we expect um to be
completed before hosting is handed over
to thailand for the for the next year
and so simply i expect in um fairly
short order we'll have consensus on
those on those two offers
it's not an issue that is substantively
discussed um at leader level as you can
imagine um but it is something that i
have every confidence will see resolve
very shortly
those two offers again
obviously
peru in the united states across 2023
and
and gratitude express for the fact that
we have hosting options and now just
some final details to be worked through
over the coming weeks
abc australia has our next question over
to joshua boscane hi joshua
good morning prime minister thank you
for taking my question um how does
australia's climate policy sit with apex
communique in phasing out fossil fuels
and
fossil fuels and were there reservations
from the australian side about that
of course all of the documents that
you've seen today have been as as apex
tradition based on consensus
um so every participating economy has
had input into the construction of those
declarations and indeed the aotearoa
uh uh plan of action uh as well
uh and from there though you can see
very tangible commitments uh and a very
tangible role for apec to play going
forward on climate policy uh i've
already spoken at length about the
fossil fuel subsidies i've already
spoken about the fact that uh as we we
have not seen in the history of apec a
real commitment to
climate policy uh uh being embedded in
future development of policy with an
apec and there's a commitment on that
and of course indigenous issues as well
but the third area perhaps i'd like to
highlight is apec
now has committed itself to developing
up a list of not just goods there have
been environmental goods that we've
sought to see
the movement
of and trade of but now also services as
i understand we're the first institution
to have done that
for us though as economies it will be a
matter of continuing to make sure we're
all held to account against the
declarations we're seeking of course to
ensure that every five years we're
checking ourselves against
our plan of action
and that is as apec has always operated
but as economies we don't commit to
those things that we don't believe we
can fulfill
fran o'sullivan from the new zealand
herald has our next question good
morning friend
good morning good morning prime minister
um you've released the artie aurora plan
of action can you tell
just exactly how that will make some
progress uh in the region particularly
we've had over the last couple of days
at the ceo summit comments from prime
minister lee and others that digital
governance is wanting
the framework of global government
governance has been criticized
repeatedly
where do you think this action plan sits
in all of that and also particularly on
digitization which is the big
transformative shift six
how do you feel this will advance uh
concerns people have about that
well of course i'd say there's two
things firstly if you reflect on the uh
the action plan
itself it does seek to improve the
competitors competitiveness of apec
economies
by encouraging
more fulsome uptake of digital
technologies to maximize
connectedness to markets and look i've
just shared a couple of examples today
where
we had for instance
utilized the opportunity that crisis
presented by working with apec economies
to digitize border processes
that allowed us to move from processes
that would otherwise have taken weeks
down to mere hours and those changes are
here to stay
and my hope is in the hope of the
of the action plan
is that those experiences amongst uh
member economies will then flow into
other areas
where there are those economies who are
seeking to formalize that
in plurilateral agreements of course
chile singapore new zealand
have demonstrated an ability to to
formalize these things through deeper
and there is interest amongst apec
economies to join into that agreement as
well but there's just one example i'd
like to think that we've really just
seen the foundations of what can be
achieved through digitalization
in the plan but also in some of the
activity member economies have engaged
in as well
okay over to eric martin from bloomberg
hi eric
good morning can you hear me yes we can
very good uh prime minister i wanted to
ask you about the um
uh about the outlook for the digital
trade agreement which had been discussed
earlier this year in which i asked you
about i believe in july
and uh whether that is still something
uh that is uh that is being considered
whether there's been any advances there
or given the lack of
of comments that we've heard
particularly coming out of the biden
administration on this uh whether that's
a plan that has been uh set aside or is
not being pursued at this point
yeah you might have i may have actually
substantively answered much of your
question
um
in my last and my last answer
uh but as i said with we've got
three uh
member economies who are part of the
digital
economy partnership agreement
and we've always said that anyone who's
able much as we do with other trade
agreements anyone who's able to meet the
high standards
within the agreement
is able to join and we have already a
process that's underway with the
republic of korea who have sought to
join the agreement
but
again it's designed to be open anyone
who's a wto member can make application
to be a part of it
it is very much alive and has
significant interest in it and his
agreement which i imagine will i will
only continue to see
interest grow
our last question comes from zhang from
kaisen please unmute yourself and ask
your question
thank you prime minister ardern um first
congratulations on having successfully
hosted this year's apac despite the
multiple challenges and i i especially
want to thank you for delivering the
opening remarks to the texans summit
that was held today
your address is absolutely highlighted
today and my question is um how has
this times uh the leaders uh meeting
this time advanced the last meetings
agenda were the issues discussed more in
depth or
more topics uh touched about for example
the prospect of the
ft aap the free trade area of the asian
pacific and how would you characterize
the atmosphere this time uh compared to
the informal leaders retreat three
months ago thank you
a good a good question
i think the reason we had the
extraordinary uh
leaders meeting earlier in the year
uh was because we saw a role for apec to
play in that time of
a health and economic crisis
and there was there were very tangible
outcomes as a result of the work and the
lead up to that meeting in the meeting
itself it allowed us to focus in on the
acute pandemic response phase that
everyone was in
then if we fast forward to this meeting
it's clear that economies are in
different spaces in their um pandemic
response
but we're in a position where we're
generally able to lift our eyes to the
horizon
and say as we continue to manage this
these pain the pandemic within our own
domestic borders
uh where are the areas that we can work
together on our uh recoveries
how can we ensure that we're learning
from one another's recoveries
and optimizing them
and you know a very clear view from
economies there was that actually we do
need to have a lens on sustainability
on the issue clearly of climate change
and on
inclusivity
when i'm in international forum i hear
the word inclusivity
used in passing but
genuinely i'm seeing it increasingly
embedded
within not just the language of leaders
but within policy that extends beyond
just making sure that in our recoveries
we've have an eye to supporting small
businesses
but much more expansively because of the
impact of the camp pandemic on women
a big focus there now and obviously
under the role that we've played as host
indigenous populations as well
so a shift in
the nature of the conversation as i say
towards one of recovery
rather than just response so that was a
big shift between meetings um to very
quickly answer your question around uh
the ftaap
you know that is an ambition that is
shared by many
members by many apec
member economies uh and as i say because
we
so clearly have that consensus built
around wanting to advance
uh open trade um and improve trade
arrangements between economies it
naturally follows that that ambition
exists
for now though you can see an increasing
focus on some of the more near-term
agreements rc and cptpp but that really
i think bodes well for future trade
arrangements within the region
okay that's all we have time for prime
minister thank you for your time
especially at this hour and
congratulations on a successful host
here
as apec chair and we'd like to also
thank the media for joining us for these
virtual media sessions this one of
course is the last and we wish thailand
all the very best as the host of apec
from new
zealand farewell
[Music]
prime minister just on the um us bid for
2020.
you